20:18 is Donald Trump's first full year
in charge of the budget and you'll
recall that even though he was
inaugurated in 2017 and for most of 2017
Donald Trump was the president it was
actually the last Obama budget that was
in place so now Donald Trump is taking
over and the headline is that the
Treasury Department is set to borrow a
trillion dollars this fiscal year that's
going to double the borrowing of 2017
that will be the highest borrowing by
the Treasury in six years and the
Congressional Budget Office which is the
nonpartisan office that analyzes budget
related matters explain that this is
because tax revenues are going to be
lower in this fiscal year as a result of
not surprisingly the Trump Republican
tax bill which is a major boon for the
very very rich so the debt is going to
go up even faster during this fiscal
year and the implications are you kind
of have to split it up into two parts
right first there's this hypocrisy of
the endless Republicans who claim to be
against deficits and against growing
debts and they got in the way of
everything that President Obama tried to
do saying the debt the deficit but then
as soon as Trump is president they sign
in gladly sign into law a tax bill that
increases the deficit deficit so point
one is they're all lying hypocrites and
I've told you that before
and I've told you before that even the
entire conversation around the deficit
and the debt these are political
footballs right the truth is the more we
learn from people like stephanie kelton
and Pavlina Chernova
both of whom i've interviewed in the
last couple of months the more we learn
about modern monetary theory we realize
that it's not as simple as debt is bad
debt down is good objectively without
looking at why the debt might be going
up or down many on the right insist if
the debt goes up it creates this
unstoppable undeniable sky is falling
disaster it's inflation it's economic
sabotage
as William Shatner says its geopolitical
self-destruction but the truth is way
more complicated first of all cutting
doesn't create economic growth that's
number one you can't cut your way to
economic prosperity period but the truth
is that the way that the economy and
currency actually work it's actually
okay to deficit spend if your deficit
spending in the right way so for example
growing the deficit to give tax cuts to
the rich is not a good way to deficit
spend it's not economically stimulative
that's what Trump and Republicans did
with their tax bill if you decide to
deficit spend to build infrastructure
not in the crony capitalist way Trump
wants to do infrastructure but if you
really do an honest infrastructure bill
that provides jobs to people it
strengthens the country it better sets
up the country to receive foreign
tourists who want to come to the United
States that's all good and its deficit
spending that is beneficial to the
economy so the truth is that deficit and
debt are way more complex than debt is
bad but Republicans and to some degree
Democrats also simply use it as a
political football and in the end it's
bogus and it's particularly bogus from
Republicans as they are set now to
borrow a record amount of money the
first year that Donald Trump's budget is
dictating what the Treasury has to do in
terms of borrowing this is exactly what
they said they would never do
endless Republicans who voted for the
tax cut bill said they would never ever
ever and all their life sign a bill into
law that would increase the deficit and
they're doing it their first budget year
that Obama is out of office and they
finally take the reins so first of all
the ideal thing would be for everybody
to learn a little bit more about how
this all works stop making the deficit
the political football that it is
because for the American people it's
actually a pointless political football
the American people will benefit from
responsible government spending when the
deficit increases in a productive way in
a benevolent way a beneficial way for
the economy that's okay and when it's to
give tax cuts for the rich it's not okay
that's the truth of the situation
but layer two is to understand the
hypocrisy right
Bill Clinton handed George W Bush a
surplus and George W Bush cut capital
gains and cut taxes for the rich during
times of war and we had a huge deficit
Obama started to reduce the deficit
again the deficit was still positive so
the debt goes up but the deficit was
reduced and Republicans say they're all
about reducing the deficit they gave
Obama no credit Trump takes over and
immediately blows up the deficit but
it's not only with the indifference of
Republicans it's with their endorsement
and it does nothing for the American
people and the misinformation that is
spread around this issue is part of the
problem because you have not only
so-called deficit hawks in Congress and
in the Senate you also have just random
Republican voters libertarian voters Tea
Party voters all of whom have also been
bamboozled into cut good-- deficit bad
with no real connection to the economic
implications of those policies the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad